you
when we left off last episode we were
talking about how men are depicted in
media taking the lens of male gaze and
looking at how men are viewed this is
the thread that we're going to continue
on today and we're going to start this
off at the extremes with someone
terrible yet popular Sam Witwicky from
Michael Bay's Transformers films ah Sam
how horrible you are picking you for
this was a stacked deck and yet so
appropriate seeing as you've drawn in
several times more money than I'll see
in my entire life before we get into
Sam's character I was asked if I could
do a bit of a theory catch-up for the
audience
especially since a lot of the vocabulary
sounds a bit well odd kind of like hey I
know those words but what you just said
didn't make any sense at all the phrase
that guy most of the attention was male
gays in communications terms gays refers
to the worldview of a given person or
group of people what do they look at and
how do they interpret it male gaze
therefore is at the most basic level how
men see the world though it more
specifically refers to the combined
forces of cultural media dominated by
men notably straight white men typically
you'll hear the phrase used in a
somewhat pejorative tone because it is
usually used from a non straight non
white or non male viewpoint so the
question that's usually asked isn't how
do straight white men view the world
it's how do straight white men view me
and my gender race sexuality that's what
makes this a bit of a tricky subject
well it is a neutral term in theory in
reality it's pretty heavily politicized
as I said at the end of the last episode
those aren't bad questions they need to
be asked and we need to challenge and be
challenged by the answers but I'm going
to avoid them because I want to keep the
focus on self identity but this is why
we're looking at Sam Witwicky
he's the proverbial man in the mirror
written by straight white men directed
by straight white men marketed by
straight white men and bought by
straight white men he is our archetype
so let's talk about him Sam Witwicky is
a tremendous waste of space he succeeds
through no merit of his own he is
aggressive hostile abusive self in
titled insecure paranoid lazy defeatist
and obsessive not only is he unworthy of
Merit he's also quite generally a bad
person or at best immature and petulant
you know what you can give me the
foundry well you won't be kidding me
and he's our hero let's start from the
beginning
what makes Sam important in transformers
I haven't quite got he owns his
great-great grandfather's glasses he
bought bumblebee he has the Allspark
cute vide uses to kill Megatron
everything that sam contributes stems
from things he happens to own not things
he built not things he found not even
things he mastered just things he
happens to own he didn't decode the
message in the glasses he didn't figure
out bumblebee secret and he didn't learn
how to use the Allspark he'll the
closest he comes to making an active
decision is when he uses the Allspark to
kill Megatron after being chased through
the streets with it anyone could have
done that he didn't set out to do it he
didn't come up with a slide plan that
went awry and it's not a culminating
moment for his character the second
movie is almost identical in this regard
Sam doesn't do anything things just
happen around him and his importance to
the plot hinges entirely on things that
just happened to be in his possession I
mean yeah there's some crap at the end
about the matrix of leadership or
whatever and how the power was in him
all along because he's something
something important but again it's not a
culminating moment for his character the
primes tell him it's because of his
courage but was courage really something
he needed to work on well okay yeah I
mean he's a coward but was that a thread
running through the film I guess sort of
not really oh and Sam is also
non-committal the entire side plot with
Mikaela revolves around his inability to
say I love you of course at the end he
does after she says at first so he gets
to win the argument and gets leadership
courage or something sorry I'm trying
really really hard to not get
sidetracked into bitching about the
matrix of leadership a machine waiting
for Sam to having near-death experience
before reassembling itself it's like
okay Sam learn an important lesson about
yourself or we're going to let everyone
on the planet die uh what yeah we're
going to let Megatron in that fallen guy
blow up the Sun if you don't believe in
yourself
you're all full of courage and stuff
that's important
look just take the matrix and resurrect
Optimus so he can fix this note to self
try harder to not get sidetracked the
best summary of Sam comes from the third
film there is once again no real
character arc for Sam from the beginning
of the movie to the end though he does
at least come up with a couple of ideas
they're obviously terrible ideas
motivated entirely by his dick and
people die as a result but hey at least
he tries what we're really interested in
though is the beginning of the movie
before all the robot stuff gets started
you know basically everything before
deep Wang that see the beginning of the
film gives us the fallout of the
previous two Sam has at this point
graduated with a business degree and is
trying to find a job outwardly the film
tries to play it as funny that he saved
the world twice but can't find a job
because he can't tell anyone that what
he was up to and also a reference to the
current economy to me but the reality is
that Sam can't get a job because he's
awkward overcompensating under-qualified
unlikable manic tense entitled an
obvious liar and he has zero references
yea they repeatedly point out that Sam
has some big names pulling weight for
him but they can't blah blah a
national-security blah blah top secret
but I don't buy that he still finished
his degree didn't he revenge of the
Fallen ends with Sam back in class and
they point out that he only missed a few
days of Dwight's physics class the
entire movie happens in less than a week
and that was Sam's first year at
university so what did Sam do with the
other 127 weeks he was in class what did
he do during the summer did he really
fail to establish any rapport with his
colleagues and professors to the point
that he has zero references did he not
manage to pull even one internship no
contacts no leads no friends like
seriously you're coming out of Princeton
and aren't even involved with some
crappy internet startup there's only one
way that could happen if Sam Witwicky
was a total douche which he is he'll one
of the first things we see him do in the
film is kick a transformer
let's let the gravity of this really
really sink in Sam's frustrated
the robots are irritating so he kicks
one when he gets in his way he
physically vents his personal
frustrations on something smaller and
weaker than himself this is the real Sam
Witwicky a bully and he's our hero and
this is male gaze
if we compare Sam to Doug what's really
changed in the years between their
movies not all that much because the
underlying core is still there
overwhelming egocentrism combined with
flailing insecurities that right there
is how Hollywood views men ergo it's how
men view themselves ergo it's how
Hollywood presents men in order to
appeal to men who are taught to view
themselves this way so that Hollywood
presents it this way to sell tickets to
oh hey it's like the next point just
found us let's talk about vicious
circles and where all this crap comes
from something we've learned in the last
hundred years is that entertainment and
reality are intertwined in some scary
ways unfortunately they're not the
really obvious ways every few years
there's another outcry about the impact
of violence and media on children or
gays or women or not on a rock and roll
Pokemon usually violence the idea is
that kids who watch violent programming
or desensitized to violence and thus
more likely to be violent this weld it's
not well it's not not true it's it's not
as true as people want to believe but
it's still kind of barely true it turns
out that media is actually kind of bad
at changing people's behaviors but okay
changing the way people think about
things and good at changing their values
in other words TV isn't good at making
you go out and vote but it can do an
okay job at making you think that you
should go out and vote and a great job
at making you feel that voting is
something good and I use the word good
in a very nebulous terms they're like a
depersonalized warm
fuzzy feeling kind of good voting is
warm and fuzzy
this means that watching a lot of
violence doesn't make you more violent
and doesn't desensitize you to real
violence but it does make you more
tolerant of the idea of violence and
especially the idea of violence as an
appropriate response in specific
circumstances here's where the vicious
circle comes into play well wait not yet
we have to talk about storytelling
efficiency okay when you make a movie or
write a book or you know whatever
there's a certain amount of efficiency
that you need to have because you only
have a few hundred pages or a couple
hours to tell a complete story most
movies just don't physically have time
to create well-rounded characters
because they have to find time to
explain how time travel exists and what
a terminator is and who has the what and
they're going where and why with it and
stuff has to blow up or someone needs to
make a poignant speech or both so even
really good characters end up being
boiled down to a couple key points and a
handful of emotions if you want to make
a movie with intense personal torment
and deep conflicting emotions with broad
implications and far-reaching
motivations then that's all your movie
has time to be about hell even then
you're probably only really taking a
look at specific ideological conflict
rather than the entirety of personal
identity so storytelling as a matter of
pragmatic reality has to limit its scope
and focus to a couple key things this is
where tropes and mimetics and
stereotypes come into play you don't
have time to develop every single
character so you have to use shorthand
for a bunch of them most doesn't screw
it all of them this feeds back into
another problem movies are really really
expensive to make so all the decisions
that are made are at the service of the
budget movies are a business you make a
movie to make money in order to get that
money back you need an audience but in
order to get that audience you need to
appeal to them you need to give them
something that they can buy into and
here's where the vicious cycle kicks in
media mimics a simplified idealized
reality watching that reality reinforces
the audience's feelings about that
worldview so media appeals to a
worldview in order to sell more units
which further reinforces that worldview
this is called reflexive feedback and
this is the problem with
Sam Witwicky apart he's a terrible
sketch of masculinity a horrible
character but is he in authentically
male well
no not entirely he's chunks of real
problems of social perception just
ground to a fine polish he's a character
that young men can project themselves
into but in doing that they reinforce a
world where Sam Witwicky is a character
the young men can project themselves
into that's why I chose transformers
even if it's a terrible offensive
generalization of everything ever people
still went to see it in droves like it
or not Sam Witwicky appeals to us on
some level this right here is who we
think we are because it's a version of
who we are but that just makes us more
like Sam because he makes it okay to
feel as insecure as we feel or to resent
women because somewhere our brains we
kind of do even if it's not something
that we act on and it's okay to want to
kick things that bug us and it's okay to
feel like you deserve the world because
your friends are super awesome robots
and even if you've done nothing you're
still so important to the world that
everyone will tell you how special you
are and you'll always be vindicated it's
not your fault that you can't get a job
it's not your fault that your girlfriend
is constantly angry with you it's not
your fault that everything goes wrong
Sam Witwicky is the meta male he is the
heart of darkness he is the oblivious
admission of our own deepest fears and
perversions he is both stunningly real
and insultingly false he is horrible
because we are horrible stare into his
eyes and face the horror
oh yeah oh my dog can can you guys fix
this but Mike my jaw is falling on
you